to welcome everybody to the world's
greatest show we spend countless hours
prepping and putting together the
greatest show imaginable in a mere two
and a half day twice a week
unbelievable what we achieve here
welcome my co-host the beautiful thank
you
voluptuous voluptuous in some ways I
think in some ways your voluptuous your
personality's voluptuous you have other
voluptuous features that I don't want to
embarrass you about there's some Vlado
embarrass you but she's here with us is
the terrific the voluptuous uh Dan Ian
in Zach thank you everybody today's
episode is sponsored by quip and Teddy
fresh today we've got a surprise that
guys put together a surprising me that's
making me nervous they're all in on it
and they won't tell me what it is it's
something I'm gonna eat apparently and
something that's gonna get more putrid
as time goes by so I am motivated to get
to that quickly I have to tell you I
always have bathroom stories no no that
one I think somebody took a dump in the
urinal what I swear to god no I think
you're right I saw it too I think
somebody would dump in the urinal I
haven't seen that since oh that's great
and they clogged it do you know how that
happens like I've walked in on a kid
taking a dump in a urinal well there's
some yes I mean I don't know somebody
took a doctor whoever would do that use
your imagination I'd like to think that
it wasn't an adult but it's crazy when
you see it cuz they have to it kind of
makes sense in a weird way like if your
kid because you kind of just squat over
it really just take a dump like that but
it's it's shocking to walk in on that
let me tell you because even a small
child knows you don't get there but so
be it
I mean I was
call you out on that story but then then
verify I'm glad dank robberies I'm
suspecting Ian of course of doing
yourself Ian has a track record Dean did
you poop in the toilet I can't confirm
or deny why are you not on the screen
I'm wondering why you're already pissing
around so that's exciting this pooping
are us in our journal I was about to
unzip and pee in that urinal and it's
it's clogged all the way in the to the
top with poop water and I was like wow I
mean this there's all kinds of surprises
I gotta tell you I really wish we had
our own bathroom
yeah and then we wouldn't have to run
and be late on our break right if there
was our urinal in our own bathroom then
that would be weird so we bring our own
porta potty inside though it'd be
[ __ ] so fast some extra room out here
now
HD feel about it and bathroom room with
our second room here if we could do that
probably not well we don't need to tell
the property manager let's just drill a
hole and [ __ ] to the basement come on
Otis either you had some drama at the
post office did you not oh yeah did you
want to talk about that I can do we want
to start off like that okay um that's
why I won't get you fired up you know
yeah okay I'm turning it up yeah come on
getting it's an injustice thing okay we
moved as you all know or not whatever
not that interesting we need to forward
the address you know to fill that
there's like a thing you fill out and
you give you a space and then they send
you your old address you're a male and
more old address to the new address cool
service by the way great for free yes so
um I went there and I asked what
documents do I need to bring with me and
everything like a good
since citizen and they told me you need
to bring this and that mmm because I
also do it from for our business so you
need to bring articles of incorporation
so I went home I printed it actually
then printed it for me thank you then
because we have no printer I feel out
the documents I go back to the post
office takes me a week and then I wait
in line I go to the person that accepts
me and then she's like she looked okay
and I show her is this here's the
documents you guys asked yeah all right
she's like mm-hmm
okay uh-huh and she's like looking at it
so oh man everything looks all right in
here and she had this like attitude
sassy yeah everything looks correct
except one thing the signature and I'm
like what
and she said ma'am I will not accept
this because you did not fill those out
and I was like what are you talking
about and she said I saw the girl that
filled this out here wasn't you a little
girl was here filling it out little girl
we're not little but you call it a girl
there was a girl here so how did she
know that she was filling out your
documents she doesn't cuz it didn't
happen
cuz I did it she could be filling out
any documents do you know what I mean
right she's insane probably so she
called ela out for not filling out the
document and I was like what are you
talking about do you know how insane
this is like I I filled it at my home
unless you have a camera inside my house
how would you know how anyway like what
are you talking about and she wouldn't
accept it so she so she's like sorry I
will not accept it and so I said well
can I talk to the manager and she
brought up another person I think not a
manager just someone else who works
there and she's like yeah okay well she
will not accept it so if you want you
can just drop it in the mailbox you know
I was like what does that mean what is
going on here so she said it's the same
thing basically you can drop it in the
mailbox sound like side any value
okay with you so I didn't even need to
bring it to you and she's like no so I
didn't so what about the documents that
you asked she said it doesn't matter
what yeah she said that you can just
drop it in the mailbox yeah
so going in person they demand a higher
quality of verification yeah
wait what that's book that means that
they could you can just forward
anybody's address right that's right
nothing makes sense I don't know just go
forward somebody's mail to my house if I
go dance work I would I know that dress
and I just drop it in the mailbox I'm
gonna get Dan's mail I don't know
apparently that's what they're saying
cuz my American that makes sense to me
that you would have to go and verify
your identification and that you owned
the business otherwise you could just
forward and buddies address to you I
don't know what to tell you but I ended
up just putting it in the mailbox and
we'll see what happens I don't think
it's gonna work I think they just wanted
you to get out of there because I know
how you get when you get fired up you
were probably going you're not happy and
rightfully so but everyone else that
works there was like yeah she's crazy
Oh play it play on my way out another
lady came to me and she was like yeah
sorry and I'm like well this doesn't
make any sense and she was like yeah I
know I'm sorry
like she was on my side I feel like the
post office employs the most
unemployable people like post office job
is on practically like welfare I think I
don't know but she's like she made up a
story it's so insane
I mean she so there you have it there's
a let's post office story pretty
fantastic but it doesn't make any sense
I'm concerned that somebody can for my
mail I don't think you could normally so
then how are they can accept years that
was dropped in a mailbox
they're just gonna throw it out probably
yeah I think so yeah I think they're
gonna throw it out I don't understand if
she saw you if she saw someone else
filling it out decided she hated me from
the woman I walked in and then
afterwards I was like um I got a pillow
box too and I last time I paid for a
third key mmm-hmm because they give you
two and she's like the other person said
it will take a week or something and it
will just be in the PIO box next time so
I check and of course it's not there
so after the whole drama saying well I
went back I didn't go to her but I went
back to someone else and I said I paid
for a third key and it's not there you
guys look into it and then they ask her
and she's like well she needs to pay for
it oh my god for it then she was like
well Denison it's the way I doubted or
like I don't know there she's in charge
she's not I don't know nothing there is
no logic at the post office we got a
problem at the post office
who's the post general master Dan we
gotta go that's a job look into it
general master that's a [ __ ] awesome
title for somebody that runs that
[ __ ] you should be the post general
master the logic it's the Postmaster
General yeah I'm sorry Postmaster
General is dope sounding idle well what
do you think I mean what do we do about
that we need through it we need some
revenge on this lady clearly Megan
Brennan
what's going on with Megan Megan you are
you are [ __ ] up I mean you always
have stories from the toilet I always
have stories from the post office yeah
oh she's retiring January 31st 2020 so
she's checked out yes what about
retiring yeah she's being forced into
retirement hmm she's been shipped she's
been what about him well that's that
that was a succeeding post office
anecdote from HeLa well thank you for
that thank you for sharing it was
fantastic that's very American
was it good how do you rate this story
yeah it was like I mean it was like a
five yeah probably I should enough open
with today I was surprised well I don't
know I'm just trying to break the ice
sometimes it's nice to break the ice you
don't know where things were go it
wasn't a bad story okay but it just I
don't think that the amount of
frustration that took place there what
does it does it doesn't yeah but this
lady's so cray
see see now I don't and I'm just
prolonging the story right I don't think
there's much juice yeah let's move on
what do you guys think back there should
we move on we should probably move on
but but I would rate it like a six on a
story scale you're being generous no no
I understand the post office frustration
up in there sucks and to Oliver I see
post lady yeah I hate the sassy post
lady yeah
post men are always nice have you
noticed that post men are helpful it's
sassy post ladies that are unhelpful and
other berrygood I've had dum-dums
yeah thumbs down from Oh Oh am I being
sexist yeah
I also we need to distinguish the okay
the carrier's the people that bring oh
there ain't no they're all fantastic but
this is purely right I've never got sass
like that from a man postman what have
you gone to the post office well okay
you're the post you got all the post
problems so you I'll take your word for
it
dumb mistake us I do all of our errands
at the post op yeah yeah you do you know
so thank you for that let's move right
along then we've got post so you know
someone sent us in they said hey I got
an idea for the first segment I want to
look at how many people how many times
the person's been in the thumbnail and I
thought that's interesting let's take a
look what was the name of that person he
gave us a list that was totally wrong
that we had to redo but we thank you for
the idea well actually this is
interesting as you can see these are all
new thumbnails and Bell has allowed it
was dumped actually so shout out the
zombies could try but no blares Bell has
has dominated so bellow pause generation
2 of the podcast that's crazy
and god bless her I'm telling you I mean
all this year - look at that purple
people say like
over bail and even in this room people
are saying that now but I'm telling you
every time we're getting clicks like
this new episodes it great
it just works you guys I mean what do
you want me to do argue against math
there were some bail stands who were
very upset at ela and I in particular
for our criticism of her last video so
but yeah what they say one was like an
essay I got like a really long yeah I
want to hear it come on don't tease me
I don't know okay well so
congratulations to her although I don't
know she's tied with Logan Paul now
Logan Paul is having a boxing match this
weekend so I think he's gonna take the
title and I have to say Bell is really
gonna have to do some extraordinary
stuff to get into another thumbnail at
this point because I think we pushed it
to the limit and as much as I would
continue to talk about it every time she
passes gas I would talk about it and I
would let Zach sniff it and tell me how
what it smelled like but but for now I
think she's gonna have to sit at eight
for a while
and I'm hoping she takes the challenge
she takes up this challenge it does
something fantastic but until then you
got Jake Paul you've got you've got a
post Malone PewDiePie Trisha is also a
contender I mean five is great yeah
people also enjoy watching Trisha I mean
I have to give it up to her she said
that she looks at episode she's in to
see if the views are higher and I mean
the interview she had with us was one of
the eyes rated as we've done in recent
uh recent history so she's got to be
happy about that regardless of the
outcome Shane Dawson Jack and Eric we
got to have them back on these are old
old Joey salads even coming in at four
Kayne chris d'elia ninja I'm surprised
chris d'elia made so many entries he's
been a guest one time we talked about it
right that was the first time when he
slammed Logan Paul famously correct and
then three times guess so so
congratulations to everybody
our big clickbait and favoriting yeah
this is interesting isn't it
I think Logan's gonna take the title
this weekend though so it's like
watching the data like in other
companies you have cells report things
like that these are a highest converting
clipping I mean they'll continue I would
put her in every thumbnail if I'm being
honest
clickbait Report quarter we need to do
this quarterly Jake has really fallen
off the interest level though I'll tell
you like he just he doesn't pull it in
like he used to you know Nick nor does
Logan to be honest but yeah I do want to
talk about that fight it's coming up so
there you have it folks don't yell at me
when I put bail because look at all
these episodes they're all very well
rated okay copy let's move on now you
guys want me to eat something you guys
have been teasing me that there's
something for me to eat you have been
saying that it's I'm gonna hate it or
love it I don't know what it is I'm
nervous and apparently it's getting more
and more putrid the longer we wait so
let's just bring out let's see what
we've got this is a Friday episode which
means guys I'm I know we're only like 20
minutes in but don't expect anything
from this episode we already spent ten
minutes talking about the post office
where it's not getting any better see
whenever people complain buy you and
they're like just let Ella host Arby's
oh my oh
I'm stoked give me the Arby's and got me
our shouldn't have no this wasn't my
idea of course but they they told me
about it you approved I proved the ELA
can we bring Arby's for Ethan yeah one
guy in particular lobbied hard for this
this is a secret menu item oh my god
that's my and it was only available at
certain Arby's and so we had to call
around to watch Arby's all over LA and
we found the one that has it was it a
long drive no it's not it's not too far
from here oh this thing is called
called the meat Mountain I wonder why
this is actually we got a second one
which I think Zach was like I mean this
so I think this one might come you want
to come and try this with him sure let
me send you on discord I'm gonna send
you the the advertising picture because
you want to be what it's supposed to
look like I mean I can't imagine that it
looks different than this how do you
make this look better than this you dude
so Zach you're gonna join me for this oh
yeah
horsey sauce or no no horsey sauce man
sent you on this cord meat Mountain pile
of diarrhea Mountain mountain a diarrhea
the biggest sandwich Arby's has ever
sold well this is an exciting episode
here guys of the h3 podcast
it's a Friday episode well I mean to be
honest and shout out to Brian Wolfe
who we actually only just saw his email
but when I searched for the meat
mountain in our podcast email he's been
lobbying for this for a long time ever
since the original RV segment he's been
like sending multiple emails like you
got to do the meat Mountain you got to
do the me Mountain so we're doing it
thank you Brian look let's super round
focus can't really see that even is this
chicken
a bunch of [ __ ] meat I don't know
it's Arby's you can't even tell one meat
from the other
okay I want to bite this thing I'm not
waiting I mean so I did rise but I'm all
for it
I did get some feedback that people
don't like the foot segments yeah
there's Wyatt where did you see that as
I what no I did tell me about that yo
how's that bitin good they don't like
the smacking mm-hmm
they find it boring mm-hmm the thing
it's unhealthy for you what else I mean
they just told me that it's a secret
item and I was like I mean so on the
front on the front you have diarrhea
okay the right underneath you have like
pastrami Swiss cheese more diarrhea
pastrami cheese fried chicken are you
gonna try Lucila no you like it
it is very good yes well it is very dry
so the description says two chicken
tenders slices of roast turkey pit
smoked ham corned beef smoked brisket
angus steak roast beef and pea bacon and
then cheddar cheese and yeah I don't see
anything about onion ring but yeah that
sounds like it's about it so how much
was this how much that oh it was ten
bucks of sandwich really not not
expensive considering I cannot believe
that you can get all this for $10 here
Ian are you gonna try this tell me the
whole thing
I don't think Dan come take a bite no
thank you
you guys that was a good idea yeah we
had we just had to see it in person it's
just so insane full of bad ideas was
that what you anticipated to happen I
guess that was the best Arby's menu I
think that whole [ __ ] thing you want
you guys one watch sit here watch he
does sandwich for 30 min no I guess not
how does that compare to you this post
office or okay
I just truth be told I thought you were
gonna hate it a lot more than yeah I
just got excited I was expecting to eat
like vomit oh and so when you guys
brought out an Arby's sandwich awesome
let's code my expectations were low so
where would you put that on a tier list
F no I don't know it's like a D you want
to say I wouldn't want to eat that ever
but a few I mean you got me all jacked
up and it's like that that's food is
like crack I mean once they hit your
lips boy I had a hard time giving that
sandwich to Zach I just wanted to keep
eating I didn't want to do it alright
get this off the screen what the Arby's
you're not even paying me pay me next
time you want to add what else Oh save
that from me Zach don't throw it out
it was two of them so well I don't want
yours you know I'm saying trash mobility
video this is the worst episode we've
ever done mobility watch this grandma
I'm telling you there's mobility people
are just they're the best okay hash
tagging oMG it says grandma's forwarding
a river on her mobility scooter
it's like blooded in jolly old England
and the grandmas just like out through
like two feet water that's fearless
that's courage that's courageous
yes it actually works oh yeah I mean
that could it be seconds before she got
drifted away to sea you know but so far
oh it worked
what a hero though what about what I
mean they just like said an old blind
lady did she know they're with water she
did you know and she's like look I'm old
I've got groceries I'm on a mobility
scooter what other option do I have I'm
not gonna sit here and wait for it to
stop raining it's now or never around
the word that's the mobility Mary of
England oh my god
beluga whale playing fetch ela thought
you'd enjoy this yeah this man is in
some cold-ass place
okay well he's got like a rugby ball
stuck in him and this damn wild Tallulah
is fetching the rugby ball and bringing
it back to the boat so the guy can throw
it again I mean right up I've heard that
belugas are very friendly towards humans
as dolphins are in general but illegals
are particularly sweet creatures and you
can see him chuck it again in the blue
it goes right back to touch it they've
got to be either you know north or south
Antarctic herb [ __ ] Iceland who knows
you know it's so magical beautiful
beautiful
too bad they'll be extinct in about 20
years along with all the other life on
Earth polar bears are really getting
[ __ ] by the way from climate change
you've seen those videos of them like
cuz the ice is literally receding so
like their habitat is shrinking and
sometimes they get stuck on ice that
detaches from the there's there's no
land left for them there's literally no
land and these poor polar bears are just
on little floating bits of ice and
getting lost in the ocean it's horrific
mm-hmm bring back old baby bear and what
do we do about it bring back whole you
know coal it doesn't pollute as much as
people think
no I'm kidding that's what they say
they're like dude coal rules it's gonna
be 2020 in in like two months dude let's
burn coal that makes total sense what do
we do about it
well for one except that climate change
is actually happening yeah man-made
climate change that's the new way of
deflecting the world do you do about
climate change yeah mr. beasts is
planting trees yeah well what what we
need to do first of all we need to mean
truly I mean most other Western cultures
all really how or I've already accepted
that okay this is a problem we need to
do something about at America we haven't
even made it that far as a institutional
governmental agencies I mean our current
president thinks it's a Chinese hoax
they think the new way of deflecting is
they say we acknowledge that climate
change is happening but we refuse to
believe it's man-made the world goes
through cycles of climate all the time
mm-hm and so that's their way of
deflecting that's clearly not the case I
mean yeah they'll find like one crooked
scientist against like ten thousand ten
thousand who are screaming with their
hair on fire and then one crooked ass
like pseudo-scientists who got a degree
he myopathy team trees are up to 14
million wow nice man I saw they got
another like million dollar donation let
me see most trees Toby
who's that Toby mark beneth Toby what
key was the yeah yeah shopify guy so
mark oh really
mark BNF is the no one know by now
ben'll Benny oh he's a 6.5 Billy
damn baby Wow he is CEO of sales phone
the sales force guy got it is that a big
company I might even familiar with them
yeah apparently you know that's great
amazing good good for you guys got boss
so good there you go we're doing we're
trying but you know young people are
really the one that have to deal with it
so
they got to be activated because though
the but I mean boomer you know boomer
yeah
boomers are [ __ ] destroying the planet
we've known that forever
it's boomers that are one that deny that
climate change is a real thing even
though they're the ones that were
burning [ __ ] cold setting the world
on fire another their grandkids are
gonna Miami is gonna flood
not that I care about Miami I mean we're
better off without it probably I've been
there once Miami Beach I mean I was at
Miami Beach bro I didn't like what I saw
I could do it but there's some there's
some nice places they're gonna go
underwater too I want to adopt a beluga
you want a beluga yeah I think we'll
need a bigger house I think we'll need
to buy SeaWorld are you sad about the
Beluga yeah he seemed happy though okay
I think the belugas are fine you can
symbolically adopt a beluga for $55 from
the WWF what WWF the world wide
wrestling federation adopt the balloon
well you can donate oh so what's going
on with balloon today they just said
symbolically yeah all whales are
endangered pretty much yeah it's
actually a dolphin more than a whale
it's so well well it is swell in the
title let me look up beluga whales let's
educate ourselves right now it is break
time by the way okay well welcome
everybody to the worst episode of the h3
podcast it is the G it's genius as
dolphin it's genius as dolphin arias
it's more it's a dolphin well there you
go
the whale is a misnomer I could be wrong
but I think dolphins and whales are more
I think it's just kind of a oh so wait
let me see if the whale is an adult sort
of the same family blue whale wiki you
may be right let's do some research here
live on the HTTP podcast worse
so ever convenience it's in a different
genius okay the blue well is in the
Balian op or triple I know baleen whales
are a separate family that's true but I
looked up blue whale whales that we're
because orcas are dolphin beluga whales
are endangered there you go
they are at threat their population
levels are other a threat they're at
threat should come out right now their
threat was can you imagine killing a
beluga whale like how old are you
they've been easy prey for hunters due
to the predictable migration patterns
and high popular population density and
also they're just sweet beautiful loving
creatures the one batch number of
animals kills about a thousand per year
three to four hundred killed in Alaska
three to four hundred killed in Canada
fewer in Greenland or Russia the
Russians haven't figured out I really
want to go vegetarian can we do it
already
hit me with that Arby's sandwich let me
just take a couple more bites first are
you a vegetarian
starting today no I'm gonna well after
the Arby's sandwich so sorry but we have
meat still we have meat in the house all
right out donut let's discuss it over
the break of which will take right now
and be right back you were not gonna
wanna miss a second of this terrible
episode that has no redeeming qualities
I'll be right back
it's quick time you know what quip is
it's an electric toothbrush that comes
in a tiny little vibrating tube it's a
vibrating toothbrush dentists all agree
that the vibrating toothbrush is the
superior toothbrush let me tell you what
else qyp does other than vibrating which
is great it times out your quadrants Oh
30 seconds 30 seconds and it lets you
know when it does a special vibrating so
let you know to switch your quadrants to
make sure that you get the perfect
minimum required dentist recommended
brush what else about clip is great it's
got soft beautiful bristles that will
not harm or damage your gums it's made
of this beautiful soft rubbery plastic
and I'm telling you I have searched for
the perfect soft brushed head and I have
found it and quit and I will never use
another toothbrush again because it's
just so soft and lovable and my mouth is
so clean it's squeaky clean you know
what that is ela it's when you rub your
finger on your teeth and it squeaks I'm
not saying as a pleasant feeling but it
is because it tells you your mouth is
great no clip starts at just $25 and
you'll get your first refill pack for
free at get clip comm / H Street this is
a simple way to support our show and to
start brushing better quip starts at
just $25 and you'll get your first
refill free at get quick calm / h3 this
is a simple way to support our show and
to start brushing better but you have to
go to get Q you I p.com / h3 get your
first refill pack for free go right now
to g ET q UIP comm / h3
and of course thank you to the lovely
beautiful multi-talented uuk wine I want
to propose once again and I don't know
if you ever seen this but ela I'd like
to get remarried to you have you ever
seen like Ring Pop because we forgot to
review these in the Candiru so out here
I present you as a fat ring boy that's a
big gem you know what I'm saying
so don't say I never did anything for
you but the reason I am giving praise to
you is first of all we need time to go
to the bathroom and second of all to say
teddy fresh calm is the place to shop
this holiday season right transition you
got the color-block hoodie and all
different the photos are so different we
have to get we have to work on the we
got all the beanies we got the best
beanies in the game I'm not gonna mince
words our beanies are the best and
people know that about us you got the
patchwork hoodie and two colors I mean
forget about it this is this is a master
class in craftsmanship you got the TF
hoodie tie-dye black white green is
everywhere I mean it's all happening at
Teddy fresh calm if you're looking for
the perfect gift if you're looking for
the perfect gift for yourself if you
want to look cool if you won't get
[ __ ] we should sell the teddy fresh
sheet that you put your dick yeah with
the hole and it says over the dick Hall
says teddy fresh oh my god
and it's like a really nice fabric
that's like almost almost good yeah
that's almost a good idea right like I
could see supreme or someone doing that
I could collaborate a collaboration with
the rabbinic a society of Los Angeles
the rabba night yeah it's almost a good
idea we think about that either for the
holidays people will want to make sure I
bet we could sell 50 of those synagogue
merch yeah like some teddy fresh branded
uh what do you call the Bar Mitzvah [ __ ]
Ted eight tallit in you in a yarmulke
set I'll be done so there you have it
guys I mean we've got it all it's all
happening you
all the time it is a steady fresh our
teddy fresh calm give it up for yours
truly you look lined the one true cool
mom alert coolest mom in the game you're
called dad
that's all I ever wanted to hear from
you and that's it
I let's get right back into the show
guys welcome everybody
I just sandwich them you want to watch
the beautiful Beluga again look barely
put it up yet so Ethan I wanted to say
yes to this but I do have a condition
what's the condition well you go
vegetarian Oh
today today right now yes right now live
on the H epoch yes can I have one more
bite yes one more bite mmm-hmm then
you'll marry me again yes
buy this ring pop the power vested me as
a trooper all right one last bite here
we go I'm serious I'm serious an owner
of that cute Beluga yeah everybody soon
is here you gotta not blink oh my god I
feel like you gotta want to go
vegetarian now this is so disgusting
maybe everyone else watching it will
also find fault with blue bill the by
the way no you do whatever you won but
this is it
so crazy
alright everybody watching we are going
vegetarian if anyone wants to join us
join the movement animal was like five
animals in there let's go all Deb okay
okay will you marry me yes alright
that's a vegetarian I hope there's no
July and then it's true we can't eat
that anymore whoa dude oh yeah I'm over
up what is dead air say something okay
um
dude cooks a whole [ __ ] camel i got a
sub cursing so much true this dude so I
think he's Turkish this dude and he
logos is this too graphic can we show
this I mean it's just cooking sure but I
I see what you're saying it's it is
beyond normal it's just a whole camel
carcass that he throws in a smoker and
well there's lots of twists and turns
you guys judge for yourself
what is this smoker it looks like a war
machine [ __ ] there a person a day hmm
it is a mini little gas chamber isn't it
[Applause]
you know I'm going to smoke a whole
[ __ ] camel ooh I didn't know the came
old me it was a thing that people ate I
mean yeah I guess if it walks it eats I
think there was camel on the meat
mountainous area
and now I'm going to teach to the camel
and he just takes a piece off like God
knows where and he's like oh it tastes
like [ __ ] I can't bring the camel back
to life and now he this is the weirdest
part injured he take them Rose sprinkles
the rosebuds on the top and then stabs
it with the rose and I mean what the
[ __ ] is that I don't know anything it
exact ah so romantic next day would have
[ __ ] this camel like what are you
trying to do got a romantic war plan
what is this guy up to I would be
suspicious if he was in the country I
would say save s s bi investigate now I
cannot bring the camera back to life I'm
so glad we're vegetarian oh dude I've
been a vegetarian for like ten and
you're wearing the rings though so
you're gonna wear that as long as I keep
my promise well that will be hard
because it's again not eating you know
scarred not eating meat neck this is a
huge so okay this is actually this one's
interesting rapper T I got a lot of heat
recently for saying he takes his
daughter on I think he said twice a year
to the gynecologist to see that her
hymen is intact to make sure that she
hasn't lost her virginity now this this
to me I was 18 she's now 18 and he well
let me just play this clip before I get
too deep into it but rapper ti who he
went on this podcast with these girls
and they asked if he's had the birds and
the bees conversation with his daughter
and so he says yes not only have I had
the conversation but I've enacted Sharia
law in my house as well
[Music]
[Music]
funny charming right because their life
you know doctors maintain a level of
professionalism is like with you know
sir I have to you know in order for me
to share information I see days you they
want you to sign these saying it like
threatening well I just want I just want
you to know that there are other ways
besides sex there behind and can be
broken right bike riding really
athletics horseback rides and massive oh
my god they're laughing at everything
not that funny
Wow
congratulate so gross so I was actually
quite really disturbed by this as most
people are were who listened to it and
you gotta you gotta appreciate how the
doctors like well this net is first of
all she's 18 dude he's like legally an
adult like that's her private
information yeah so she has to sign a
form consenting the doctor to tell him
and he's like threatening her but it
doesn't mean anything that's such a
stupid like old-school thing what is
can I ask you I don't understand what's
that I've never had sex with a virgin so
I don't really understand what's this
whole hymen I don't even know if like
whatever mine broke or whatever you
would call it at some point I don't even
know why didn't happen know how
apparently when you lose your virginity
yeah but not only so yeah not only do
you guys have any Intel about the hymen
have I mean it's just a small like
membrane of tissue in a vagina that you
know breaks at one point sort of like a
seal but yeah I mean if freshness seal
yeah I mean but yeah I mean
traditionally people kind of took it as
a sign of virginity but as you just said
it can break any number of ways and you
know it I think it's long been
discredited as like a way of determining
virginity anyways so it's just have you
guys ever broke a girl's hymen no I have
never taken a girl's virginity so go
ahead I'm waiting for the other two yeah
I have and so
did anything I was 15 she was also 15
and yeah it was a it was a bloodbath oh
wow I was confused it doesn't always
have from what I understand it again cuz
I haven't done it but the either bleed
so tiny little bit or something it just
depends you know yeah he's different
I thought he'd burst when like a woman
gets her period for the first time but
no I yeah it was um so you guys were
doing your thing yeah and did you were
you both surprised by the bloodbath yeah
was it a lot it was like a lot of blood
just it's gushed out oh man or did you
stop I stopped
I'm like you know like I helped her like
got some towels but like him did that
ruin the moment yeah yeah yeah I'm kind
of glad I never had sex with a virgin to
be honest it seems pretty not it seems
like I mean I'm sure it's so was it a
beautiful thing or was it kind of like
it was very traumatic
probably it was very primal and IANS
probably Ian's probably busted a couple
items no I don't have a blood bath hmm
well so if you if you have a hymen can
you get a proper like vaginal exam like
how they give you the pap smear and all
that does it cover that hole cuz I my
Anatomy on that female genitals is not
high level I'm not entirely sure I don't
think so that's recovering yeah I
thought well why do you need a path to
be right headset yeah I thought a woman
can get it till she's 21 is that correct
get what pap smear maybe cuz I don't
think I had it when I was young well
they do it to check for cancer yeah no
you get you get it before 21 okay
well according I think T is different
daughter's gonna be virgin till long
after that it's so weird why you so
possessive of your daughter and who she
has sex with creepy pretty psycho and
you know T I [ __ ] like a thousand
girls too maybe not I don't know
but he did by the way also um I don't
know like if using tampons will affect
it but like almost everyone uses tampons
and I don't I feel like that would also
where is the hymen it's over that hole
yeah
or it's below that hole like I need some
sex education that's like any side you
know hymen where's the hymen don't show
my screen I'm just I'm looking I need
some sex education I'm gonna have to
teach teach Theodore about this stuff
someday let's see
it's a hymen as a membrane that covers
the entry to the vagina the hymen is
located deep inside the vagina so if I
put my finger in too far the hymen will
break
oh wait that's a question I mean as
close to the entry oh yeah only one to
two centimeters inside the vaginal
opening
once yours fingers inside it can reach
clear until the cervix without injuring
the hymen how is that possible tell
hymen I just read that it doesn't like
really technically break it just
stretches out so right it's all like
each person can be so different the
whole thing is just done according to
this website the first time is a myth in
itself for many women the first time
that full penile penetration occurs
naturally happened only after several
times of experiencing partial
penetration with each experience the
hymen stretches and eventually becomes
flexible enough to easily accommodate
the penis so there you go doesn't even
really bring a sense of like ripping you
know why what and also like women like
sex - like why why are you depriving her
of that it's a way of life you know what
I mean and if he has sons I'm sure he
doesn't treat them like no he doesn't
care he's like he's on here telling them
go [ __ ] some [ __ ] by the way and I
was curious what she thought of it so
his daughter was liking tweeds this was
one tweet says this is disgusting
possessive and controlling woo she liked
that give me my results first of all
mf'er those are her results like WTF
liked this is beyond possessive
it is beyond possessive it makes me feel
like he wants to [ __ ] her I hate to say
that but it's like what are you what why
are you so obsessed with her vagina I
think it's just super possessive
possessive but then for what purpose
I've gotta be the right guy and he needs
to approve because it's just it's like
really old school it's like oh she's my
little daughter and you are not good
enough I'm gonna be the right guy
and she's not gonna be a slot yes she is
gonna be and that's like the mindset
yeah I know I still find it I I don't
understand it well there you have it tea
eyes of weirdo man and why is he talks
kind of like a southern plantation owner
and I said and I do and I do uh
expeditiously
he's from South expeditiously I'm happy
if we have a daughter I'm of a hard time
even I don't think I'll be able to talk
to her about her vagina at all I'm gonna
have to leave that up to you and guy no
visitors I mean you gonna have to get
over it I'm over it I feel like it's so
funny that like this topics are so
sensitive like the period mm-hmm
it shouldn't be the vagina is a very
mysterious place there's a lot of ends a
lot of outs it shouldn't be because it's
a it's like when a girl is on period
she's gotta hide it's like well I agree
that that I agree that we get it every
month and we suffer every month why do I
always also need to hide it right like
I'm the one suffering here look I'm a
pro I'm a proponent I agree and I'll
tell you what else I own shocked by the
fact that you have to pay taxes on
tampons that shouldn't be a tax [ __ ]
tampons the sales tax that's insane it's
like a female tax literally you need it
it's like there's no tax on groceries
hmm why should the via tax on Tampa ever
thought about that yeah because when we
were broke like that's kind of like a
big expense that stuff do temples are
super expensive yeah all their like
feminine stuff not just the tempos you
know this is pretty much just a straight
up so women in tax yeah because men
don't have to worry about that obviously
so I I'm not on it they don't have to
worry about it they also get to pretend
like it's not happening that's what's
annoying right because it's like oh I'm
not supposed to talk about it because
it's gross I don't mind if you talk
about it from me I know but I'm saying
but I said there's like a cultural thing
I totally that is the atmosphere the
first time I was confront so internally
we had a co-ed bathroom with showers
different they we had our own stalls but
was a co-ed bathroom and sometimes I
would go in the bathroom there was like
period blood falls to the bottom of the
toilet you know and Bulls there it like
doesn't combine with the water right and
that was the first time I was ever
confronted with the period huh as I saw
period blood in the toilet and it
shocked the hell out of me but just
because you know I'm sheltered and I
think you have a good point there you'll
that being said I mean but I don't know
anything about the vagina I got to talk
to her daughter
yeah about her like that's what my learn
you don't know anything about a baby and
what's going on with the baby and
you're learning mm-hmm learning
fascinating I'm not an expert I don't
remember when you get your period or
what like when you're a parent it's
gonna be different you have to be the
one like who knows what's happening
that's why we have a mom that's why we
love mom no I'm saying I don't feel like
I know necessarily what to say
what she's okay well we don't with
daughters we don't have a daughter
yeah I wonder if there's any weird talks
you're gonna have to have with Theodore
I don't mind talking him about sex about
using a condom and all that okay so what
do you mind about a girl I guess I don't
know like taking her to the gynecologist
and stuff but the way that he's so well
that's insane the way that he's so
obsessed with her genitals it's just
creepy
if weirds me that makes me feel icky
when you guys were growing up was there
a parent you felt more comfortable going
to things with when it came to the birds
and the bees I didn't feel comfortable
with anything with either of my parents
I didn't do anything with them I feel
comfortable with anything with my dad so
yeah can you imagine your dad taking the
other guy into college you know oh my
god no both my parents didn't tell me
anything about anything I just found
porno that's how I learned about sex I
found my dad's a porn stache that's how
I learned everything you that's the
great love maker I am that was some
serious [ __ ] that's why every time
you'll have sex I started like this I
went in the movies it's really not much
to it you know you just got a you I know
it's awkward you just gotta do it I
think it's so important like I wish that
my dad would have sat down with me at a
young agent and and taught me a little
bit of things mm-hmm
but you never got you never got to know
I never got I never had a talk my
parents didn't teach me [ __ ] about
anything I never got to talk to you that
I wish that I would have got to talk my
parents just pretend that nothing
happens I was show what about like crazy
yeah my cousin my dad my dad sat me down
what did he tell you explain the whole
thing slide it out yeah
at what age yeah well hey um I'd say
probably like 12 or 13 and did you
listen and were you interested yeah and
I mean you know I had figured out a
decent amount of it yourself but no I
mean I think that is important and yeah
I mean it was like a little
uncomfortable but I think him doing that
was beneficial in the sense that it made
me much more comfortable with things
later on because it just kind of
normalized it because it wasn't
mysterious you know so your parents are
like the the most normal parents I've
ever heard of it sounds like well did
you guys have talks Zaki Dan uh yeah
it's kind of like what's the same age
for Dan like 12 13 but like I used to
watch a lot of like raunchy cartoons and
that would talk about it but when I was
like five six I thought the way you got
a girl pregnant was he peed in her I
used to talk to my friends and like I
couldn't believe that you know that's
awesome yeah some of these teachers were
having kids I'm like wow a lot of that's
[ __ ] that's so cool you know girls we
should say that in high school when you
were wanted to say you were attracted to
a girl you'd say I would pee in her but
I'd be in her but Ian tell me about your
talk I never got one thing I expected
more to have it but I guess we're 50/50
out here sounds like so what did you did
you just have education three of us
didn't get it most didn't yeah I'm
definitely giving theodora talk no
question I think it's important for men
well for parents now to talk to their
kids about kind of like like educating
them on what's okay and like where women
are comfortable with boundaries and
stuff like that - yeah that was part of
the talk to him really I think that's
really cool I mean I think that's that's
really great I think that's really good
that's really cool that's awesome yeah
you're right I mean I guess there
probably are a lot of kids that grow up
that just know I feel like that I feel
like that's a big part of the issue when
you're looking at all this me to stuff
is that young men are growing up without
a male role model that show them like
what's okay and what's not or at least
telling them like these these are limits
that you need to be aware of that in my
life I've become aware of and this is if
you see if a woman is uncomfortable then
you should definitely stop and wait
until she's comfortable you know what I
mean like just saying that to a young
man I think has a big impact that's true
yeah that's very impressive of your both
your parents yeah I mean again yeah it
definitely was like a little
uncomfortable especially like you know
the first few minutes of like having
that conversations like oh god this is
did he have like a banana in a condom no
no banana he did show me how a condom
work so unlike his thumb or whatever you
know just kind of explain what it is and
yeah I mean I think it was again because
it was like you know I figured out a
decent amount of it myself I wasn't
completely ignorant it wasn't coming
into a blind but you know it just kind
of approached it like do you have you
know are you unclear or like you
confused about any of this stuff and you
know just kind of made it a little bit
more just normalized again oh good
because it sets up the expectation that
you can talk to them about it right and
I think was a big part of it too
yeah I never felt like I could talk
about anything right yeah which
I didn't really but I knew I could you
know yeah I learned a lot from listening
to Stern a lot too so it was more love
line for me but yeah that's interesting
like that uncomfortable barrier with my
dad was broken because we used to listen
to Howard and stuff like that
did your dad give you a condom
demonstration no I'm gonna when I teach
Theodore my bring a huge black dildo no
I'm son this is black aam you know what
you know it really [ __ ] him up
you know these builders are really
popular now these bad dragons they have
like dragon like if a dragon had a dick
they imagined what it would look like
and it's like this is like a crazy thing
no a bad dragon but they have do like
the look of like the biggest craziest
one bad dragon calm custom handmade
fantasy sex toys there's these really 12
they have like horse [ __ ] and it's yes
and so I'll show you I'll be like done
son this is what a penis looks like
wait are you looking - yeah yeah they
also make a fleshlight of like the alien
from Avatar
I'm not I am i probably can't show that
you know as you keep scrolling down and
gets weirder I'll come at Theodore with
this giant dragon this is what every
what every penis looks like section here
describe what you're seeing for the
people listening I just I mean the the
further you go down the weirder it gets
I mean there's one called Ridley that's
just straight-up is an alien from aliens
as a dildo yeah how does it have like
arms or what it's not no it's like as if
it
the alien from aliens dick I guess I see
yeah exactly it's like colored and
pattern that way and everything I see I
need points for creativity yeah there's
one called Winston's tongue and it looks
like it's supposed to be a gorillas
tongue I'm assuming Liam from bro watch
yeah oh my god so there you have it
folks how do we get here oh yeah
shoenice is back in the news everybody
shoenice is eating raw bacon now I don't
think enough shoenice says that this is
okay because it's cured but I actually
don't believe did you talk to shoenice
down that closing I have not replied to
him it's you nice if you're listening
I've gotten your your 15 emails and back
to you soon shoenice just for the record
I told Dan to call you to get on the
phone and see if we can work out a time
to come on the show if you don't hear
from him it's Dan's fault not mine it's
been a busy week it's been a busy week
we're setting up a new office and
everything's we got to tell uh I think
we're having fish tonight for dinner we
have to put a stop to that you have it
look scheduled we have a thawing in the
fridge put a stop to that
then do you eat fish I have that's like
the one thing that I have broken the
rules on it's not it's not very common
though in fact did the last time I had
any fish was probably like two years ago
okay
I'm not I don't want fish yeah I never
understood not even while I make an
exception for food I think just because
they think it's healthy it's not no it's
not really bad I don't know it's not
sustainable fish are [ __ ] dying yeah
all right so it's not better in any way
that is true except it's healthy I think
I think part of it is that when you're
vegetarian for a long period of time
like red meat and chicken and everything
stops being appetizing like it kind of
mm-hmm
it becomes gross looking to you and for
what
reason fish doesn't I don't know it
looks like a different thing interesting
and it's every time that I've done it
it's been at sushi like a big group of
people going out to sushi and it's just
like fine I'll have like a roll or
whatever but like I said it's been a
couple years so what about raw bacon so
we've got shoenice here with a hanger of
raw bacon and again he says that you can
eat it because it's cured but I don't
believe that well basically this is the
six slices of raw I think yeah cured
bacon uncured is the stuff you don't
want to eat this is fine I've eaten raw
bacon since I was three and now I don't
know I wouldn't need any of that [ __ ]
okay
do you know much things like you know
the white right yeah when you cook it
all this packets cooked off I mean it's
still fat but on your mark
that's just horrid this isn't a
challenge by the way no one else is
doing that
I feel like shoenice just puts his
dinner or like on a rat and like the
last time he just down some key bosses
but they never might as well make a
video right how is he still alive I
really wonder we need to study him she
said he's been doing this since he was
three Oh God that's [ __ ] oh that's gross
shoenice that's the daddy right that
can't you can't even chew it it's just
oh dude this is so discussed this may be
the most disgusted I've ever been in my
life
I'm actually not sure what sound sound
no
[Laughter]
do it dude that's why it doesn't kill
him because he downed a whole bottle of
vodka afterwards everything is done he's
just swallowing the whole thing you know
it's funny this guy's gonna quit alcohol
and then he's gonna die because of all
the [ __ ] he's eating is gonna kill him
without being sanitized okay can't even
cure it it's just he said did I blink it
this is wrong there's Mike what no he
doesn't say that's his dinner man he's
got he's got to make the best of it can
we not watch this is the challenge ELA
the challenge is to watch the whole
thing do you think he cleans that hangar
just puts it back on this is clothing
shoe nice Wow
no thoughts no thoughts just brain
damage
thoughtless I had my headphones off I
couldn't listen to it we're done yeah I
just looked it up yeah the the cured
bacon thing that's that's not real it
was three maybe
he's built up a community or something I
don't know what's going on there I hope
that he's dead yeah that he is gonna
dedicate his body to science when he
passes away I feel we could learn a lot
from him yeah could someone bring me a
diet coke you mean a Coke Zero yes okay
thank you Anna are you [ __ ] with me
where's the pizza
okay so Popeyes Chicken is back I didn't
know that it had gone away what's the
deal with Popeyes did they sell out a
chicken and then they just got it back
Ian I'm asking you you're the keeper of
culture uh yeah they ran out and it's
back now thank you Dan thank you so much
and so how's the chicken place running a
chicken I don't understand that it's
been like a month too
but the chicken is back it's been back
about a week or less and I have here
three fights on separate occasions at
Popeye's ian said he went to Popeyes on
Wednesday and saw people almost get into
a fight so he could share an anecdote
about it that's what so Ian do you have
an anecdote about a Popeyes fight yeah
kinda I mean I went and the line was
huge and as I was waiting this guy in
front of me was on the phone and he was
kind of drifting in and out of the line
a little bit and at one point I think
people thought that he wasn't really in
the line mmm and so when he went to
reenter the line these two guys behind
me were like what the hell do you think
you're doing and he was like oh I've
been waiting here for a long time and
they were like if you're trying to cut
me right now you better get the [ __ ] out
of here and they were like they're like
we're New Yorkers okay you don't want to
[ __ ] with us and he was like all right
man I'm not trying to get in some [ __ ]
at a freaking chicken store and then he
he left but he was there but I gave out
for him no I I didn't want to mess with
their New Yorkers so did anyone nobody
stood up for the guy no I mean these
other people were whispering like I
think that guy was here and I wasn't I'm
pretty sure he was yeah I mean he was
behind me but you were waiting in line
how long did you wait in line uh maybe
like 20 20 minute and that was for your
own enrichment for your own Popeye so
much I wanted to remind my it was pretty
good you gotta remember it was a pretty
good so no I was dancing but I would and
it sounds like a zoo down there two
people just fighting yeah it was crazy
and then as I was waiting and I hate the
waiting in the line - I felt like a
shame that I was
yeah and as I was doing that someone
came up and right after that guy almost
got in that fight and he was like are
you Ian and I was like I don't want to
be seen here this is embarrassing
were you by yourself yeah I was picking
it up for somebody so are you doing uber
are we not paying you know don't know
pretty after they know like I was gonna
go eat it with a friend of mine Wow
the base did the fans stick around and
talk with you did they like walk the
line with you no they were very much
like I'm trying to get out of here - I
don't want to hang around it's violent
in there's no it's poop eyes I saw
someone refer to it as poop eyes on
reddit and I thought it was great
cuz it makes me think of pinkeye like
you're getting poop in your eye poop
eyes so that's well thank you for the
anecdote here we've got three clips from
one week and apparently Ian narrowly
avoided a fight - you're there to
drive-thru you know how there's like -
drive-throughs and they intersect well
they couldn't decide who would go first
and so they crashed into each other and
now everyone just wants to kick it I
mean I had the chicken it's good I would
not do this I would not put myself
through this I don't get that is it just
the hype that everyone wants chicken why
did you go there hand is it just the
hype I just wanted to try and with a
friend of mine just see it's so good
it's a good sandwich she's all here yeah
yeah it is good I gotta give it up but
still man
I'm not going back that was it and I
feel bad for all the Popeyes employees
that have had rust on them now it's not
like they get paid more yeah every day
is like hell for them now forever by the
way I wonder if Popeyes stock is up do
that are they publicly traded sure doc
so did they never have this chicken
sandwich never had the chicken sandwich
and prior to this Popeyes was probably
one of the least popular fast-food
chains so like if you worked at Popeyes
over the last year
you probably had like the chillest job
until a few weeks ago well just became
[ __ ] hell it's great that you guys
bring that up because there's one here
where they you can see what it's like
for the employees of fight breaks out
inside Popeyes and you can see the
effect that has on the employees here
liveleak of course all the best content
they're having the employees are just
like it's just chaos so supposedly what
happened here was that one of the
employees was selling chicken sandwiches
out the back door it's premium you know
what yeah and so a fight broke out in
the restaurant and you you could see I
mean one girl comes up and is just
serving people their order everyone is
just chaos everyone just wants the
chicken
this girl's given to get out stuff I'm
not going to pop by Friday is that a
double entendre Black Friday this guy's
off watch they're hitting each other
with the fryer oh my god dude he said
once again they're fighting so you have
to assume he flee there there's another
fight from poop eyes a white guy starts
calling people
the n-word with a hard R and and and
then he gets jumped and they steal his
chicken yeah no that's great dude
tension is high at Hot Buys man they
just wore them and then they cook it
right outside hey kid Sam that's the
best part that's not like all that why
did going on at Popeye's the Boomer
debate is really heating up speaking of
the n-word that's what they I know I
know it's a bad segment no the white guy
said the n-word
I didn't say that word I would never so
someone wrote an article saying boomer
is the n-word for older generations
which is hilarious boomers have been
getting super upset over the fact that
okay boomer has B
I'm a common insult this tweet started
escalating it when it went viral and got
mega ratioed it had one point six
thousand comest 159 likes a few days ago
let's see if this sweet still up was a
blue checkmark yeah you're stomping yeah
what was that Zach was just running to
Dan up a drink shaking the whole damn
building replace is that Arby's sandwich
got em thickened up yeah he's this guy
said replaced boomer with any ethnic or
cultural minority does this tweet still
read okay do congratulations Twitter
you've invented the words first age'
slur okay boomer so then it picks up
steam it really sets off Monday morning
when a conservative talk show host Bob
lawns berry not to be confused with Brad
berry tweet it out and then now deleted
tweet he said boomer is the N word of
ageism being hip and flipped does not
make bigotry okay nor is it a day right
a derisive epithet acceptable because it
is new Wow quite a take first of all
comparing it to the n-word is like
already makes you such an idiot you're
just an old boomer ass idiot only a
Boomer would compared to the n-word
boomers are [ __ ]
I don't like boomers in general on
Bayona on a person-by-person basis I'll
pick and choose but as a generation
boomer suck we've been saying that for
years and only now I'm happy to see the
boomer I've been called boomer by the
way I get called boom Oh fun people say
Hughes down what does it even mean any
baby boomers you know
it's calling you a woman it's like
saying all that a touch mmm I get called
boomer all the time I'm the Internet's
favor favorite boomer
mm-hm I've been called I've heard people
say that about me do you accept it
I accept boomer sir you're a self-hating
boomer self-loathing boomer yeah
I'm Uncle Tom boomer and uncle uh what's
it what's a uncle Gary boomer I don't
know do I need to make an apology about
the previous no we're past that now
we're apologizing order some few know
ela then I'm looking to you well for
answers we're fine we're fine for what
you don't need a forehand sex there's
nothing to apologize for
we clearly have good intentions we're
trying to be politically correct it's
difficult to know I mean I'd be worth
more worried about offending boomers
right now then black people like Ian and
don't worry I've trust me it's fine no
boomers watching the show so who cares
welcome
what is the generation their dad yeah
that is a Boomer yeah Technic all of our
parents would be boom boom whereas 46 to
64 oh that is the worst Abreu's you know
what they called the World War two
generation the Greatest Generation
yeah we were discussing this the other
day it's kind of unfair that they get
that name could they were the greatest
that was insane still little
self-aggrandizing I don't think they
named themselves that it's like a
historic him back dude they definitely
got the greatest journey
dude they earned it that was [ __ ]
they have to go fight the Nazis and you
had to do it to those that Davos it was
so [ __ ] up about this then you had to
go fight him they were that evil the
nominees were the greatest generation -
were they great no it's a reference to
the merit so that's like the generation
before the Boomers yes world war two era
so they were the greatest generation
and then their sons their children were
the baby-boomers because everyone came
back and that babies like this is
specific to America
yes yeah pretty much gotcha I think it's
somewhat applies it's America it's an
American American because we can Israel
no it's a it's an anthro law and
anthropological and thorough illogical
anthropologists use these terms these
are classifications that they use a real
scientific terms to classify generations
okay I was just thinking to compare like
our parents my dad in your that they're
kind of the same age yeah it's exactly
the same yeah so yeah my dad is like
when he when they came to Israel there
was like no country
well today you would have your own
generation yeah distinctions there I
mean the circumstance of their
upbringing is completely different so
they are kind of like the badass
generation in a way I'm sure you have
clear generational titles but I wonder
whose doubloon I don't think there's a
boomer generation what's equivalent well
we call them the boomer generation
because they know we make fun of them
because they had it super easy yeah they
grew up during like the most economical
advantageous time they went to college
for like $15 they bought houses for like
$20,000 they have they own all this
property and they all had good jobs and
now that our our generations got the
short end of the stick in terms of like
college healthcare housing is skyrocket
out of control and now they look down on
us and meaningly like I'll get a job buy
a house you know pay for your own
college it's like well college
comparatively is like a thousand times
more expensive my dad paid I think a
thousand dollars in total or less for
his entire college grade his whole at
UCLA and we got dying whales we yeah
exactly they polluted the earth they did
all this terrible thing and now not only
do they look down on us like we're lazy
and they don't want to help solve the
problems that they
like destroying the earth and so that's
why people from our generation give [ __ ]
to the Boomers because they say it's
this whole attitude of well I went I was
a bar I I worked at a grocery store and
paid for my own college and bought a
house it's like cool if I work at a
grocery story I'm pretty much homeless
if I work full-time in a grocery store
and Los Angeles pretty much you have to
live with like five people to make that
work yep yeah so you know that's why
they get [ __ ]
[Music]
so there you have it but the great
generation certainly deserves that title
how dare you Dan yep yeah where were we
what are we talking about
boomer being like the n-word
yeah boomers not the n-word you are
boomer ass idiot just accept it dude
it's just boomer and also it's just it's
literally your dictionary.com as an epic
quote that they they have this is
awesome that they quote to ated him
who's running these a social accounts
man dictionary.com quotes we did this
guy he said they said boomer is an
informal noun referring to a person born
during a baby boom
especially one born in the u.s. between
1946 and 1965 the n-word is one of the
most offensive words in the English
language so dictionary.com was even
dunking on this guy
that's pretty bad that's a very boomer
attitude to be like to be like as so
privileged and then all the sudden to
put yourself in the category of being
ages ageist into something comparable to
the n-word it's crazy
so the boomers aren't down but I think
that if anything that just makes people
want to say it more of course it does I
I thought that was old money
are calling it ages you know I mean look
how people treated this poor girl Greta
what was her name Anita Greta nope well
Greta was right yeah I mean literally
people said about her I don't know I
mean it was just outrageous help people
of really boomer generation uh-oh just
missing her because she's young
yeah just [ __ ] on her for being like
this ignorant little girl but she's dead
on about everything she said you know
well good for her I like her
boomer ass [ __ ] I mean our president is
a boomer is that right uh he'd be on the
upper end of it but yeah for sure our
president is a boomer you guys just let
that set in I'm sick of these old
presidents man I want two young supple I
want a man with a supple stone you know
what I mean oh yeah that's funny I
looked at um are you doing something for
the show yeah baby the baby boomer
generation but I looked it up in Hebrew
because I was curious that's why I doing
my funk so on day like celebrities that
are boomers or I don't know what to call
them and so they got Steve Jobs Bill
Gates Bill Clinton boomer boomer and
then they do have Donald Trump here yeah
Donald Trump is a Boomer City actually
the one Bill Gates is a pretty is a good
boomer there you go
and you don't like Bill Gates oh damn
you such like a sliver is your dad's a
total lip [ __ ]
wait why what did he do to you Bill
Gates yeah Bill Gates is a ruthless
businessman what are you talking that's
the Tuck yeah that's what they said
about him in the 90s but now he's one of
the greatest philanthropist of all time
yeah that's great that he wants to give
away all his money that he got by
ill-gotten gains that's cool
it's not ill-gotten come on you're such
a socialist did
dance like a hard left buddy invented he
didn't invent anything he stole
everything that he made millions of
dollars off of getting a lot of dog I am
this these this is not that sounds in
disparity theory didn't he win his
antitrust law lawsuit against the
government well there were a lot in the
late 90s and no I don't think he won all
of them they they didn't get a lot of
penalties and stuff but moreover I mean
Windows was stolen I mean from though
from Xerox Xerox yep where zero zero
nowhere because he stole her technology
and crushed them sounds better yeah
dance sounds pissed okay no not you they
sound you know some will make it that
far
tell you why I think Bill Gates is being
like a con like just because he stole
something it would be the richest man in
the world have more to him than that Dan
let me tell you something you cannot
write off an individual based on one
thing in their life he is a boomer by
definition finding money hold on that's
not true Dan he's been out of Microsoft
for a long time the guy's like literally
saved so many lives
yeah he's eradicating diseases in Africa
yes he's doing more than freaking Amazon
guy Jeff Bezos don't give a [ __ ] about
the world yeah trying to beat Elon Musk
who's trying to space suck is a Boomer
suck see but here's the thing about Bill
Gates he's transcended being a Boomer he
was a Boomer when he was a ruthless
businessman but now he's transcended and
he now he's worried he's helping the
world he's working on eco energy he's
working on eradicating diseases he is a
philanthropist he's a great guy and to
be frank with you Dan if he paid 50
percent of his money into taxes I think
that he was spending that money in a
better way than the government would
okay okay well decide with Dan here
didn't Zuckerberg steal facebook for
the Winklevoss oh we're not saying
anything nice about Zuckerberg nobody's
saying anything nice about suck that
guy's a piece of [ __ ] but
about anyone successful there's only
always gonna be all this um you know
people are gonna try to go and get them
too so I don't know how how legit is the
point that Xerox or making I don't know
yeah they didn't when you're successful
you become a target is my point so I'm
sure there's truth to what Dan says he
was a ruthless businessman he was
I mean Microsoft you know I mean but
ultimately I don't know that it's fair
to to reduce him to that as a human
being and everything he's done in his
life to just say Oh mark Bill Gates is a
terrible human being he was a ruthless
businessman I mean he's doing a lot of
good [ __ ] right now say he was adorable
you can't he never redeem himself in
your mind I mean what does that mean I
mean redeem himself I said he's a flanch
which he's doing a lot of good stuff
he's a good boomer you disagreed with me
you said he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah well
so the work that he's done eradicating
malaria in Africa I'm not going to
dispute that that's a positive thing but
look up what he's done with education in
the United States do a little bit of
research on that and then we can have a
discussion about it what has he done
what back what could he have done that
was so bad with education the United
States he he created this fact it's a
long story
do we really want to get into this sure
I care Friday so he he made all of these
charity efforts I'm trying to remember
what the name of the foundation is Bill
Bellamy about it well it's part of the
Bill and Melinda a foundation or
whatever
Bill Gates u.s. education I mean
certainly is whatever he did his
intentions were pure no I mean maybe I
don't know k-12 education yeah I mean as
soon as you just look up Bill Gates US
education it's all these articles about
Bill Gates please stay away from
education yeah he spent like billions of
dollars with this philanthropic
organization to try and steer schools
into
all of these kind of experimental you
know Silicon Valley style education
methods and everything and all of the
schools that he dropped all this money
into their results went like they like
plummeted like it just like wrecked
everything and he since like abandoned
the entire the entire effort because it
went over so poorly so well I mean I
don't I don't fault the guy for trying
something our education system isn't
necessarily a good one
I mean we have one of the lowest rated
educational systems in the world what's
up I don't think that's true honestly
dude of the developed country the United
States has one as one of the worst
educational systems of the developed
world I'm serious
people come from all over the world to
go to school here well public university
I'm talking about public education not
higher education some states are really
terrible but some are quite good okay
boomer okay dance hit me with that
boomer mentality egg time I think we're
all boomer this debate is on all the
rails in short our president is a boomer
and we want someone with a young supple
sack with a not droopy you know how
droopy Donald sack is it probably goes
to his [ __ ] knees probably probably
wears a diaper to keep that [ __ ] in
check I want a man whose sack doesn't
droop shorter than the tip of his penis
that and that sadly disqualifies me as
president but there's someone out there
with a nice supple sack waiting for the
waiting for the job do you know what I'm
saying
to women's vaginas have the equivalent
of droopy balls does your [ __ ] sag when
you get older more I don't know you've
measured
hmm how's you guys as ball supple balls
going
it's called meat curtains accent you can
say that into the mic but I don't I
don't think that's a result of Aging
I think that's just something there's
just the way your genitals are let's
hack ok I got really quiet back there
what's going on asking about my balls
yes we are your balls they're great
they're great they're they're tight high
and tight I don't believe you ok I'll
show you after the few guys a ball hang
or one like yes I'm maybe gonna ask Ian
boy you guys who try to make this the
worst show ever tell me about your balls
he is the greatest show ever made all
right let's move it on you guys are not
helping me little kid tells his teacher
to STFU mmm that's not right
[Music]
so like I had this comment comment
perfectly capture it's my feeling
immediately made me laugh and then I
felt really bad for the kid yeah because
you know his how his home is just horrid
but there's something incredible about a
kid just screaming Marley yeah that poor
kid man sure you hears that a lot at
home there you have it that's that story
okay how long we been going too long how
long and let's see are you over it then
it's a hour 50 we got the debate about
boomers we got the face thing face
Jarvis I don't care well you want to
debate this with me faze Jarvis [ __ ] I
don't care and nobody cares about this
[ __ ] he cheated in fortnight he got
banned for life and me and Dan were
debating if the punishment was just but
I don't think Dan was to debate with me
anymore
think he's about me calling him a Boomer
who would have thought that it would be
Bill Gates that would come between us it
is pretty shocking stand up for that guy
I like Bill Gates and I don't understand
the story there's plenty of there's
plenty of rich people that just sit on
their [ __ ] gold coins like smog Lord
of the Rings reference
there are plenty of people he's not he's
not the worst thank you okay thank you
also stills come back okay all right we
got the NSA's not the word but from what
I understand they donated like 250
million for the education thing yeah
it's like I just I doubt that his sing
you some articles like I got to do a
little bit of real once it's a nuanced
discussion shares like wasn't really
prepared to have right now yeah what I
will say is that I'm sure his his
intentions were probably you know I mean
he's not just trying to ruin the
educational system but I you know it's
possible he left them just high and dry
and made a mess of them left you know
that's kind of what happened yes and but
again my issue is I'm not taking issue
with him trying to do good things I'm
talking about how he got the money in
the first place beings coming that's
good it is good that he's trying to do
something good with it I agree with you
at least he's not just like sitting on
it like Bezos I just gave half to
divorce ex-wife became the third richest
woman in the world just by divorce yeah
so awesome is it woman or just third
richest person pure woman well it's just
woman specific okay that's pretty well
so sick here let's talk about it one
money as well we're doing good on time
right you uh it's only 2:15 so here is
this guy face Jarvis played he played
for tonight with a aimbot and he knew he
was gonna get banned now when I heard
this story I thought he was playing in
secret keeping it a secret and just
trying to pretend like he was really
good at the game but that's not what
happened what happened was that he made
a video being like hey guys someone told
me about aim bot I didn't believe them
and I actually got it installed and I
want to make a video showing guys what a
mod is and so they'd made a new account
he even did it on a new computer because
he knew how severe it was that it would
ban your IP they don't take to a lightly
Innes someone who's played a lot of
competitive gaming counter-strike and
all of that I mean there's nothing worse
than cheaters they ruined though
integrity the whole game here you can
see them playing downstairs right
somebody has given javis what are you
doing right now bro what are you doing
JAMA just firing - nothing like killing
people actually pro players made this
video and he got banned here he got
banned as he expected he would so what
happens next his epic was like oh no no
no we saw the video we're gonna ban you
you real-life you for life from playing
the game and participating in any
tournament you're done this is a
professional player he's you know I mean
you know he's a professional player
select any a professional athlete you
got that level of dedication of training
here he is crying
Nevers as everybody enjoyed there's
nothing better than teary-eyed apologies
nine million hard for nine community
Dan's laughing just like I think these
are real tears this is gonna prevent you
from going to any other crash this kid's
Bill Gates as far as dance I just wish I
could have known how badly I was messing
up because I would never have ever
thought of even making those kind of
videos you get that yeah you know for
him it's more than just not be able to
play again he's like I can't go to
tournaments and see you guys I can't
play with my friends I mean it's this
whole life his whole life revolves
around this game phase Jarvis and he got
banned for life so Maya my initial
reaction to this was that it seemed like
a over maybe an over reaction by epic
because when I like I said when I first
heard about the story I thought he was
like competing and pretending he he
didn't have a bottle and which is acting
like he was that good if that was the
case and I said yep ban that guy for
life but he was making a one-off video
just showing what aimbot he's a pro he's
in a pro team phase in articles they
just referred to him as an entertainer
and content creator
well they streamed boomer boomer
terminology I mean he's in phase which
is a professional gaming team so that's
why I say that obviously I don't know
but he participates in tournaments and
stuff so when I realize it was just a
one-off video then I did I felt bad for
the kid I mean they could have suspended
him for like six months a year but the
lifelong ban seems I mean I understand
where they're coming from because you
want to deter they said they stress in a
statement they have a zero-tolerance
policy for the use of cheating software
the pro players were teaming where
Jarvis was modifying the game itself
also what cheating in eSports is
damaging aimbots and similar game hacks
sour the game for many more people I
totally agree with them I mean there's
really nothing worse than cheaters in
this game but the fact that he wasn't
hiding it the fact that he was kind of
showing it showcasing it as a one-off
video makes me think they just didn't
think it through just died and he's 17
he's a kid I could see myself doing the
same thing at that age just trying to
make an entertaining video not thinking
of like the the far-reaching consequence
of it and they I mean look I get where
they coming from with a lifelong ban I
[ __ ] hate cheaters in these kinds of
games I despise it I just wonder why not
like a year or something that could you
serve your time and then you have
another chance well Dan disagreed with
me Dan Dan strongly disagree with me on
this point well I mean mostly it's that
this is their policy of how they treat
cheaters and if they were to go lenient
on him I mean just because just because
he's a streamer like that he got special
treatment and I mean I'm sure that would
cause a huge backlash in the other
direction you know what I mean like if
they went lenient on him well most of
what I said it as most people can just
go make another account or make another
IP address or play over a you know a VPN
or something but so because he's famous
they were able to ban him right and so
he can't go to terminus he can't play
the game anymore
he can't not play the game right I mean
well theoretically they wouldn't want to
do that to anybody who's cheating the
game they don't have the ability to but
in his because he was dumb and
advertised it tried you know monetized
it and turned it into content him
breaking the rules
it made him an easy target for them I
think if you think about like another
example to you know because if they had
gone lenient on him or only band you
know
one accountant known as other one that
would essentially be advertising that
you can get away with doing this like
just going I mean yeah well that's why I
was suggesting something like a year
been that would have sent the same
message I feel like a year ban you know
you know that abate their policy than
sure but again if if that's the rule is
that if you use you know they're trying
to deter people from doing it use the
software you get permanently banned from
the game if they don't do that to him
then he's kind of getting special
treatment I don't know that I mean it
takes a lot to get banned from other
professional sports even Mike Tyson was
able to box him wasn't he after he bit
Evander zahl it feels ear off I mean
it's soccer for example I mean what do
you have to do to get banned for life
I guess maybe drug use yeah I mean if
you that's your doping I think you do
get banned for life from you know
betting I know betting can get you
banned for life like I mean there there
is instances does doping can't you ban
from life I know there was a huge doping
scandal in baseball where all those guys
banned for life I don't even think so
Barry Bonds they didn't ban him but he
is the all-time highest homerun record
so there's an asterisk next to it yeah
hmm well that's not yeah but he got to
keep playing I'm sure he got suspended
yeah but that's the thing I mean it's
it's it's an interesting problem as we
you know as this professional video
gaming eSports becomes more and more
popular there I don't know I mean he
could have been one of the great players
and now he's banned for life
I guess maybe just him so severe like so
harsh for life I'm sure I mean it's a
good deterrent I get where they're
coming from but I do feel bad for him I
do I looked at I see that yesterday it
seems like ninja agrees with you he's uh
he's come out and interesting said that
he shouldn't be banned for life yeah
because again it's like if he was trying
to compete with that in secret then I
would say fan that [ __ ] yeah
like it's totally different but he
wasn't he wasn't hiding it he was just
doing something dumb you know
so I say free Jarvis free phase Jarvis
did he take phase out of his name was he
kicked out of phase not and I've seen
those guys don't have any morals they
don't care they give him a second phase
phase phase Jarvis free fairies Jarvis I
say give him I say give him a one-month
ban I say give him a three-month ban and
let the kid play let him play the game
remember that game a movie Rudy were the
football player he was like dumb little
[ __ ] and he couldn't play football but
he just wanted to play and then at the
end everybody goes Rudy Rudy you know
what I'm talking about and you guys do
that with me Jarvis Jarvis Jarvis ja no
no I'm not chanting for Jarvis sorry dan
was dan was coming down hard on Jarvis
coming down hard you softened up since I
last spoke to you I mean I feel a little
bit of sympathy but I haven't changed my
mind you think he should be banned for
life
yeah [ __ ] cheaters dude like [ __ ] that
imagine all he's doing is ruin the game
for other people like think about the
other people are on the receiving end of
that yeah how annoying and shitty that
no I'm not angry but I agree that it
should be punished but I just the
severity of I guess maybe leave it but
the thing your ban it might as well be a
permanent ban in the exactly then been
one year he's only 17
ban him for one year but he what dancing
is the game ain't having me popular near
and he's it's like a lifelong ban I say
three months I think that's what I saw
ninja said doing me like three or six
months free Jarvis that's what I'm
saying next up tick tock is a Chinese
data farm super popular but did you know
the tick tock was bought by Beijing
owned by dance
technology in a 1 billion dollar
acquisition of us social media apps now
US lawmakers have been calling in recent
weeks for a national security probe in
the tic-tock concerned that Chinese
companies may be censoring politically
sensitive content and raising questions
about how it stores personal data isn't
that awesome the tenth on owned by China
and I don't trust you I don't just
general [ __ ] you know they're crazy if a
Chinese government or if a Chinese
company owns something like this you
know the government is looking at the
data if they want to mm-hmm
they don't have an option it's like pure
tyranny over there
it's like tyranny plus it's like tyranny
with a little extra thank you how funny
like if at the end of everything it's
tick-tock that would affect the election
oh yeah take tax gonna bring us down
richer now it'll be Facebook again I
just thought you know that was a big
press release about how every
intelligence agency like ten of them all
made a joint announcement saying that
our upcoming election is going to be
attempted to be persuaded by like Iran
China Russia and for us to be vigilant
be aware and all I could think of
meanwhile was Mark Zuckerberg being like
hmm
time to get paid baby cuz recently he
went in front of Congress and he's like
i'm i don't think i should ban political
ads with the election coming up are you
kidding me
maybe after the election after we make a
billion dollars they're like an hour new
president is Vladimir Putin Vladimir
Putin is winning all 50 states
tik-tok is growing popular among us
teenagers at a time of growing tension
between United States and China over
trade technology about 60% of tick-tocks
26 million monthly active users in the
United States are between up to age 16
and 24 with over 110 million downloads
in the United States
tick tock is a potential
counterintelligence threat we cannot
ignore Schumer and cotton wrote to
Joseph magic wire Acting Director of
National Intelligence I don't notice a
his name my Mac Maguire Magikarp tick
I'm so bad at names I don't know how
anyone's but expected to pronunciate
names correctly I mean I think they're
getting worse but I don't I've never
read these names before Maguire I guess
I should have known that one tick tock
allows users to create and share short
videos with special effects the company
instead the United States user data is
stored in the United States but the
Senators noted that bite dance is
governed by Chinese law
tick tock also says China does not have
jurisdiction over content of the app
which does not operate in China not
influenced by foreign government but US
employee said moderators based in
Beijing had the final call on whether
flag videos were approved the former
employees said their attempts to
persuade Chinese teams not to block or
penalize certain videos were routinely
ignored out of caution about the Chinese
government's restrictions and previous
penalties on other bye dance apps so
they're basically censoring the content
there as if it was Chinese audience
because again they're afraid of daddy
China restricting because China could be
like sorry you can't operate in the US
anymore
so they gotta suck China's dick mm-hmm
that's everything
all right dan how are you feeling now
that we're finished with the showdown
are you relieved are you happy how you
feeling I didn't realize we're done okay
Zack how are you feeling fantastic in
you haven't said much I want to hear
more from you why you not why are you
giving non-vocal responses I got a piece
so bad
gave a thumbs up it's a thing I gotta
press the button I got a process it's a
whole thing
you got plans this weekend I thought it
was supposed to help
now it resulted with less talking right
I'm here I'm here
what do you want to know what do you got
planned this weekend I am going to a
meet-and-greet after this for a musician
I like and then a movie name and of
Hussian fka twigs Jesus you are really
underground man put out an album today
it's very good I highly recommend it
it's a girl yes
is she underground she came out not bad
underground can you repeat her name
again fka twigs fk8 whit what does fka
stand for I mean I know formerly known
as is what's that's usually useful
that's how she's used waves so I don't
know but she put our great album so okay
well I'm impressed when you do any stuff
what movie are you seeing the lighthouse
I want to see that this weekend - Oh
Jason was in town video game donkey and
Leah they told us to watch that movie
really high rating at night then because
this is our last night with a babysitter
oh we fired our what we did fire we just
if we faced it out so we have no more
babysitting time during the night and we
should go see a movie but I'd rather
spend it with the dogs because with the
baby and the dogs is like I don't have
any time for anybody I feel bad and when
the baby's sleeping I want to be with
the dogs because I don't have any time
with them if we go to a movie these poor
guys are gonna be at home by themselves
and then when we come you know do you
know what I mean it's like I'm gonna be
with the doggies
there's sweet little guys should see the
movie the dogs to lightkeepers tried to
maintain their sanity while living on a
remote and mysterious new england island
and the 1890s
I heard it's a a comedy like comedy
horror uh I don't think you would call
it a comedy but I guess it's funny
there's probably humorous aspects to it
but no I don't think it's a comedy is it
a horror film or is it like suspense I
haven't seen it yet it looks pretty
spooky it says it's a gripping story
brilliantly filmed and led by a pair of
powerful performing powerhouse
performances
you know I'm warming up to the idea of
the Twilight guy being Batman he's
apparently very good in this movie so
I'm warming up that's been in quite a
few other Michael Keaton can be Batman
than anyone can that's what I'm saying
what how dare you but if you look at a
picture of Michael Keaton you would
never think Bruce Wayne that's the great
famine I think he's a good Batman but
like oh just something looks
yeah if someone's like Michael Keaton is
gonna be Batman I'd be like what you
know what I mean yeah he's a he's a
great Batman look at this Batman I guess
it could I don't have that feeling yeah
I guess it could be
what about oh it's a shame we never got
the Segal Batman movie he doesn't strike
me as superhero ass but Val Kilmer was
probably worse bad I feel like he does
he's got that face he does have kind of
a Bruce Wayne vibe doesn't he does like
older Bruce Wayne wiser Bruce Wayne
you've received the Nick Cage Superman
screen test
no wait was he auditioning for Batman no
no Superman look it up it's [ __ ]
hilarious
Superman audition this yep no way this
is real it's very real why Superman bald
the [ __ ] is crazy you really you've
never seen this before no oh man if
that's forward a little bit when he's in
the full suit it's [ __ ] great you
think that thought is gonna [ __ ] us yeah
rubble turn it off so that goes under
the suit so it looks jacked yeah I guess
so
that's pretty cool dude right now he's
like hell yeah I'm gonna be Superman I
lost my mouse here it is is that audio
just like just music general music yeah
dude with long hair take a look at that
flower that is so bad even in his mind
he's like really yeah that's right it
was gonna be Tim Burton movie Tim Burton
oh that makes sense
yeah Superman lives well and he made the
original Batman's so he knows what he's
doing his hair why Superman a mess he's
supposed to his hair he's what suit
looks lik hybrid of the Joker and
Superman right I think Nic Cage would
make an amazing Joker actually oh that
could actually be good yeah I think he
would be that suit is awesome he looks
so jacked
yeah I'll shine E and [ __ ] I love how
he's just casually chatting with whoever
that is is that Tim Burton yeah it looks
like Nick Cage its reflection in the
mirror that's why you wanted he gives
everyone the same hair as him everybody
every male lead in Tim Burton Oh has
that hair oh that's funny
oh Beetlejuice - yeah everybody why is
this even the females have that haircut
everyone has the same hair what do you
was this like was he actually casted for
this cuz otherwise why is oh so much
effort you know like well that movie was
never made so I wonder if it was just
canned for some reason yeah I think I
got cancelled
it was scrapped that's a shame I wonder
why I'm sure that how fit looks amazing
dude that would be great if the Superman
was like middle-aged dim balding
receding hairline like it doesn't make
oh that's right I think the script was
by Kevin Smith so how did that go wrong
that sounds amazing yeah I don't know it
just didn't end up ocular it's crazy I
gotta get me in that suit I love how
he's talking to like he's like his
mannerisms as if he's in like a Andy
Kaufman is that his name yeah Andy
Kaufman he's the guy that made
adaptation right Charlie Kaufman Charlie
Kaufman his mannerisms like he's in a
Charlie Kaufman movie but he's Superman
what a kook what a kooky is the director
all right that's it we're done
all right everybody thanks for watching
happy Friday happy weekend everybody
stay blessed thank you for watching till
the end of a free podcast extravagance
of the worst episode of the best show
ever
it's still better than the best episode
of the some of the better shows out
there follow you dig yeah I follow I
don't know if I know meat no meat no
meat no meat
you don't eat meat anymore vegetarian
fed fetch fetch fetch vegetarian I'm
gonna try okay how it goes
I will try my best but only but men are
supposed to eat me I'm gonna be a
soybean if I don't eat bacon raw bacon
I'm gonna be a beta male and and I have
to eat raw bacon like shoenice according
to Jill Rogan shoenice is the ultimate
alpha male he's right - Marge face game
things Marge face it's crazy so we're
gonna get so shoenice if you don't hear
from me it's dance full mm-hm
I give you use address go visit him not
me go to the post office and get
afforded you should we should try that
we should go undercover and see if we
can afford like I don't know it doesn't
make any sense she even asked me for my
ID she asked me for all these documents
and then yeah and she's like oh just put
it in the mailbox I don't know what
happened there
so the lady asked you for your ID and
all this yeah and then after verifying
some else filling it out yeah so she
it's almost like she made the decision
to [ __ ] you over yeah afterwards yeah
that's what a [ __ ] so weird
I didn't do anything I walked in like I
didn't do anything I done something you
didn't do and you're probably looking to
flying she got better
were you looking fly that day no
probably you were you look fly every day
mm-hmm you're probably looking to fly
all right have we done the music stop
dance then it stopped a while ago it
played again we got the music back No oh
my god do you gotta tell people that you
forgot again
what happened to you tako and that he
made people say because last time he
forgot you told people if you're
listening until now comment like what
everything was so funny and then he saw
all those comments and he thought those
were actual computed so it happened
again
Ethan's now out here with us Joe chose X
camera alright have a great weekend
everybody will see comment Ethan look so
good this happy so it is really um is
that the fitting window is really
working they go okay goodbye I see you
next to you there
[Music]
you